vamos a ejercitar la memoria en nuestro
último vídeo estábamos viendo ecuaciones
paramétricas y tomamos las ecuaciones x
dt era igual a haber recuérdenme x dt
era una función que dependía de t y era
igual a 10 + 5 veces t
esto lo estamos construyendo en el
último vídeo y ya dt por su parte era
igual a 50 estábamos separados en el
punto 50 menos 5 veces de cuadrada
si nosotros gráfica vamos esto recuerdan
que graficar nunca se dañó entonces lo
voy a graficar otra vez y si nosotros
hacemos la gráfica de estas dos
ecuaciones paramétricas obteníamos una
parábola se acuerdan si teníamos que en
el punto donde te valía 0 eran en el
punto 10 50 y empezábamos a y ahí era
donde nuestro móvil empezaba a caer
hacia el precipicio y hacia la nada
entonces teníamos que te igual a 0 era
aquí y si te valía 1 estábamos en el
15,45 y si te valía 2 estábamos por acá
y si te valía 3 estábamos muy cerca de
llegó a la 0 y además nuestro móvil que
ahí entonces lo voy a dibujar así
pero esta gráfica realmente es una
parábola y los parábolas también tienen
el lado izquierdo entonces vamos a
suponer que te puede tomar valores
negativos y lo voy a poner con color
rojo entonces con el color rojo o
anaranjado
una combinación de los dos voy a poner
lo que pasaba con tiempos negativos
entonces supongamos que te vale menos 15
x menos 1 pues me da menos cinco y diez
menos cinco me das cinco pero por otro
lado esos en x pero en el lado de pues
me queda que menos 1 al cuadrado es 15
por 15 y 50 menos 545 o sea estaría aquí
ahora bien si te valdría -2 pues tenemos
por acá y si te valdría menos 3 pues
tenemos por acá recuerdan que estas dos
como decirlo estas dos ecuaciones
paramétricas lo que realmente te dan es
una gráfica de una parábola y es una
parábola con propiedades importantes
porque lo que sí sabemos es que tenía un
sentido el sentido era para ella para
acá iba a nuestra parábola y nosotros
cuando llegábamos al punto más alto
empezábamos a caer y fíjense lo hermoso
de estas ecuaciones que nos están
diciendo la verdad nos están diciendo
que realmente tenemos que caer hacia
abajo perdón la redundancia pero es muy
importante esto no están diciendo esto
en nuestras ecuaciones ahora bien en el
problema que teníamos era un problema
real no podíamos tener tiempos negativos
y si ustedes se acuerdan el tiempo
estaba acotado porque de aquí en
adelante caía nuestro automóvil hasta
llegar con el sueldo y darse un buen
trancazo pero antes de eso pues no
sabíamos de hecho más bien sabíamos que
venía en una vereda en un precipicio
ahora bien esto nos da una idea de poder
acotar el tiempo el tiempo empezaba en
cero
acababa pues donde tocábamos con el piso
y al chocar con el piso esto nos daba
que llevarle a cero y esto lo hicimos en
un cálculo muy rápido a la vez pasada
pero ahorita me gustaría profundizar en
este cálculo si lleva de cero pues
entonces podemos despejar de aquí a de
cuadrada vamos a hacerlo si ya vale cero
entonces tenemos que cero es igual a 50
menos 5 t cuadrada y lo que quiero yo es
despejar a t bien pues ahora pasaré el
otro lado el 50 y cuadrada y lo voy a
pasar sumando
entonces me queda que 50 cuadrada es
igual a 50 y ahora si divido todo entre
5 pues me queda que te cuadrada es igual
a 10 y si yo paso a la raíz me va a
quedar que te es igual a la raíz de 3
entonces en este punto de aquí va a ser
la raíz de igual a la raíz de 3 no quede
3 ni que estos ocho cuartos es la raíz
de 10 estaba yo pensando en el resultado
que de hecho la raíz de 10 es como 3
punto y cachito eso yo les había
comentado en el vídeo pasado la raíz de
10 es cercano
o al 3.1 por ahí anda más o menos bien
entonces en el tiempo 3.1 es cuando
nosotros llegamos o tocamos el suelo de
hecho si se dan cuenta estamos tomando
el sentido positivo de la raíz cuadrada
la raíz cuadrada positiva porque si
nosotros tomamos la raíz cuadrada
negativa es decir menos de raíz de 10
tomaríamos con el otro extremo de
nuestra parábola es decir donde corta mi
parábola en el eje de las equis perfecto
entonces lo que sí quiero yo contarles
es que esto era en un tiempo positivo y
un tiempo negativo pero nosotros
sabíamos que el móvil al principio iba
por el precipicio hasta que llegó un
punto en el que empezó a caer si
nosotros quisiéramos describir cómo se
movía el móvil antes de eso pues no
podríamos hacerlo pero bueno si podemos
hacerlo pero no con estas mismas
ecuaciones con otras ecuaciones
distintas y entonces como nosotros
teníamos un problema real
ya tenemos acotado el tiempo el tiempo
está entre el cero
y la raíz de 10 bien
ahora lo que yo voy a querer hacer es
escribir estas ecuaciones de una manera
que me graphic en una parábola pero una
parábola que no dependa del tiempo sino
que sea una parábola como nosotros la
conocemos ya iguala a una función de x o
x igual a una función de y entonces lo
que voy a hacer es ahora una un proceso
que se llama eliminación de parámetros
con este método la idea que está detrás
es quitar a la t y poner a x como
función de ayer como función de x pero
voy a escribir de nuevo mis ecuaciones
paramétricas tengo que x es igualdad 10
más 5 t y que 50 menos 5 t cuadrada era
igual a y ahora para eliminar el
parámetro mi parámetro que éste lo que
tengo que hacer es pues despejar de una
ecuación a te voy a despejar de esta
ecuación que es la más fácil ate para
ello puedes sustituirlo en donde bate en
y
ojo se puede despejar arte de cualquier
ecuación
yo voy a despejar de la primera ecuación
porque es una ecuación lineal y si yo
despejar a de la segunda ecuación pues
me tendría que quedar una raíz cuadrada
por ahí que es la verdad no quiero
sustituir y no me quiero meter más
problemas así que pues sustituyamos me
va a quedar que x menos 10 es igual a 5
t o dicho de otra manera si yo divido
entre 5 pues es x en 35 menos 210 entre
52 es igual a tres días después de la
primera ecuación entonces ahora lo que
voy a hacer es meter a t o sea a equis
entre cinco menos dos en la segunda
ecuación sustituir a t en mi segunda
ecuación para que me da una nueva
ecuación que tengo que es igual a 50
menos 5 por t perote es x entre 5 menos
dos
al cuadrado todo esto elevado al
cuadrado entonces pues aquí apoyo
simplificar un poco y es igual a 50 voy
a cambiar de color 50 menos 5 x pues el
cuadrado del primero que es x cuadrado
entre 25 menos dos veces el primero por
el segundo o sea cuatro quintos de x más
el cuadrado del segundo que es 4 y esto
era y ahora hay que simplificar un poco
que voy a obtener que lleva a ser igual
a 50 menos 5 y ahora voy a multiplicar
el menos 5 por cada uno de mis factores
adentro de mi paréntesis entonces tengo
que menos x cuadrada entre 5 porque pues
el 5 con el 25 se van y ahora cuantos
menos cinco por cuatro quintos pues es
menos más 4x y menos cinco por cuatro
pues es menos 20 y el 50 y el 20 yo los
puedo reducir todavía entonces que me va
a quedar con otro color que es igual que
no lleva un poco más clara porque está
estaba muy oscura y es igual a menos x
cuadrada entre 5 + 4 x + 30
bien y aquí ya tengo una ecuación que
solamente depende de x y nosotros
teníamos o partimos de unas ecuaciones
paramétricas y haciendo la eliminación
del parámetros obtengo una ecuación que
solamente depende de x y ya no está
involucrada aquí te ahora bien qué
pasaría si nosotros quisiéramos graficar
esta función bueno lo primero que quiero
que se den cuenta que es una parábola y
si nosotros hiciéramos la gráfica con
mucho cuidado de esta función vamos a
obtener ni más ni menos que la parábola
original la que teníamos allá arriba es
decir esta de acá esta que voy a dibujar
the swell va a ser nuestra parábola
cuando eliminamos el parámetro bien pero
yo sé que ustedes me van a preguntar
ahora oye sal y entonces si teníamos dos
ecuaciones paramétricas y aquí yo
solamente tengo una ecuación de guía que
depende de x porque es necesario tener
un tercer parámetro porque es necesario
tener una tercer variable t no es más
fácil solamente tener esta parábola y ya
pues la respuesta es no tengas mucho
cuidado pues se pierde información sin
el parámetro t no sabríamos si
recorremos la parábola hacia él
o hacia la izquierda entonces realmente
lo que estamos haciendo es perdiendo
información
además si nosotros nos damos cuenta en
la ecuación que tenemos aquí abajo ya no
depende de ti entonces ya no sabríamos
dónde está nuestro móvil en algún tiempo
si nosotros quisiéramos saber dónde está
nuestro móvil en el tiempo 1.25 pues ya
no habría forma de saberlo recuerdan que
en la gráfica que tenemos arriba
nosotros sabíamos qué pasaba con
cualquier tiempo por ejemplo aquí en el
tiempo igual a cero aquí aquí en el
tiempo igual a uno igual haya 2 igualdad
3 en el tiempo igual a raíz de 10
etcétera entonces lo que acabamos de ver
es inservible pues las respuestas que no
lo que acabamos de ver nos sirve para
simplificar las cosas en alguna gráfica
o en alguna idea rápida
que tengamos nos va a servir la
eliminación de parámetros sin embargo
dese cuenta que el tener una ecuación
paramétrica nos sirve mucho porque nos
da información adicional de cualquier
manera nos vemos en el siguiente vídeo
cuídense mucho